Привет! Этот урок подготовительный. Его задача, чтобы у тебя всё работало,
всё было установлено и ты мог спокойно начать учиться. Разберём три вещи: как получить доступ к
нужным сервисам, как за них платить и в каком инструменте мы будем работать весь курс. Сразу
главное правило — оно пройдёт через весь урок. Почти всё, о чём я сегодня говорю: доступы, оплаты,
обходы — всё это постоянно меняется. Что-то перестаёт работать, появляются новые способы,
исчезают старые. Поэтому точные шаги мы держим не в видео, а в текстовом гайде. Он будет в описании
под этим уроком. Гайд — твой основной источник истины. Идёшь по нему, по шагам внимательно,
ничего не пропускаешь. Он обновляется, за этим и сделан текстом, чтобы держать всё актуальным,
а не перезаписывать каждый раз урок, когда что-то поменялось. Это дольше. А здесь сейчас,
в этом уроке, я объясню, зачем каждая вещь нужна и как сейчас в целом устроена ситуация. Чтобы,
когда ты откроешь гайд, всё в нём было понятно и осмысленно, зачем ты вообще это делаешь. Начнём
с того, почему вообще всё это нужно. Большинство сервисов, с которыми мы работаем, из России
напрямую не открываются и не дают собой пользоваться. И блокируют не по одному какому-то параметру,
а сразу по нескольким. Первое — это геодоступ. Сервис либо вообще не открывается с российского
адреса, либо открывается, но не даёт зарегистрироваться. То есть смотрят твою геопозицию. Думаю,
это и так понятно. Второе — это оплата. Российские карты не проходят, даже если ты внутрь зашёл,
то на шаге оплаты тебя разворачивает. Третье — это верификация по номеру. Часть сервисов,
особенно самый нужный нам это Клод, на этапе регистрации просят подтверждения по SMS и российский
номер им не подходит. Можно авторизироваться и через Google, но там тоже свои нюансы.
Четвёртое — это бан по IP. Адреса, с которых заходят массовые или которые уже засветились в сервисы,
помечают и режут. А ты, если пользуешься VPN в свободном доступе, то не знаешь, кто-то ещё под этим
IP сидит или нет. Поэтому это всегда риск. Это четыре основные преграды. Каждый из них по-своему
обходится. Поэтому дальше мы по очереди разберём, как через них пройти. Сначала про доступ — это VPN,
потом про оплату и аккаунт. Первая наша стена — это геопозиция. Для этого нам нужен VPN,
мы уже знаем, что это такое, но не любой. Вот что важно понять. Возьмём, например, обычный VPN,
бесплатный или популярный из тех, что у всех на слуху. Даже если ты в Телеграме там взял какую-то
подписку за 400-200 рублей — это всё фигня. С этого IP-шника могут заходить десятки, а то и сотни людей,
на те же самые сервисы, которыми ты пользуешься. Когда какой-нибудь Клод или Google видит,
что с одного этого IP 50 разных устройств на Андроиде, на iOS, с Windows заходят все с одного
этого IP, то он, конечно, это видит, сразу помечает и тебя банит. Поэтому твой IP, даже если у тебя
там, не знаю, открывается Инстаграм и всё работает — это вообще не то же самое, что пользоваться такими
сервисами, как Клод или Google — это совсем другой уровень внимания к частоте пользователей.
Поэтому сразу говорю, если твой VPN там суперсекретный какой-то, я не знаю, платный, в надёжном
проверенном сервисе и так далее — нет. Он работать у тебя корректно, скорее всего, не будет. То есть,
возможно, даже впустит, даст где-нибудь зарегистрироваться, но потом через пару часов забанит.
Поэтому делаем по гайду. Там всё описано, как сделать себе корректный VPN. Мы отдельно сделали для
этого даже микро такой сервис, чтобы тебе было удобно. Поэтому идём строго по гайду. Вкратце об этом
подходит — ты арендуешь свой зарубежный сервер, который именно там находится в другой стране
железно. То есть, даже в России есть возможность арендовать зарубежные сервера. У нас тоже есть
такие сервисы, но они перенаправляют трафик. То есть, всё равно видят, что это трафик из России. В гайде мы
показываем, где надёжно тебе этот сервер арендовать. Соответственно, этот айпишник закрепляется за тобой.
Больше никто им не пользуется. Ты разворачиваешь на нём свой VPN. Ну, как ты. Это автоматически происходит.
И всё. На этом сервере только ты. Он надёжно работает. Он не сбоит. Скорость твоего интернета не зависит от того,
как много пользователей сейчас на нём же сидит. Поэтому чужие VPN нам не подходят. Мы делаем свой.
Вторая проблема — это заплатить и получить доступ. Тут два пути. У каждого свои плюсы и минусы.
Путь первый — это своя собственная подписка. Ты оформляешь сервис на себя. Плюс тут, конечно, в том,
что это полный контроль и стабильность. Всё твоё, никто не вмешается. Минус — заплатить из России сложно.
То есть, наши карты не проходят. Тебе нужна зарубежная карта. Плюс тебе нужен зарубежный айпишник.
То есть, опять же, VPN. Плюс тебе нужен будет ещё номер телефона для регистрации.
Тоже зарубежный. Соответственно, ты можешь самостоятельно этим всем пользоваться.
Если у тебя есть всё зарубежное. Тут ты получаешь как бы полный контроль, стабильность,
если у тебя эта инфраструктура выстроена. Но если нет, если даже у тебя там телефон с одной стороны,
карта с другой стороны, VPN с третьей — это также привлечёт внимание и ты можешь получить банк.
Путь второй. Самый простой — это купить готовый аккаунт. Кто-то уже за тебя всё оформил,
оплатил. Ты просто получаешь логин и заходишь. Покупаешь на любой доступной площадке.
Например, на платимаркет. Я часто беру там. Есть и другие, но это такая самая проверенная.
Аккаунт не совсем твой. То есть, кто-то ещё имеет к нему доступ.
У меня, конечно, проблем с этим никогда не возникало. Ну и файлы все у нас
сохранятся локально на компе. Поэтому никто ничего у тебя не украдёт.
Ну и ты платишь комиссию продавца за то, что он всё это дело настроил.
Плюс в том, что если всё-таки тебя как-то спалят и забанят,
ты сможешь пожаловаться продавцу, они тебе заменят этот аккаунт.
Это что касается Клода — самого основного инструмента.
Если это что-то попроще, например, Figma аккаунт, там его за 600-800 рублей можно взять на полгода
со всеми возможностями и подключения Клода к этой фигне и так далее.
Но это мы ещё обсудим в соответствующем уроке.
Поэтому, если готов париться, чтобы у тебя всё было своё, то, пожалуйста.
Но имей в виду, что нужно всё делать аккуратно, смотреть, опять же, строго идти по гайду
и выстраивать для себя эту инфраструктуру.
Если не хочешь париться, готов чуть-чуть переплатить.
Если не хочешь париться, готов взять чужой аккаунт или аккаунт, на котором ещё кто-то сидит,
то есть тоже цена варьируется, то можешь воспользоваться вторым способом.
Но только к Клоду он не относится, там, наоборот, чуть-чуть переплатить придётся.
Теперь про основной инструмент.
Весь курс мы работаем в Клод Код.
Давай я расскажу, почему именно он по всем плюсам и минусам.
Первый достаточно хайповый претендент - это кодекс от OpenAI.
Он дешевле, результат у него приличный и он стремительно растёт и развивается.
Но до Клод пока всё-таки не дотягивает.
Для кодинга он подходит хорошо, но на задачу другая, мы занимаемся дизайном.
Второй - это курсор.
Стабильный, заточен под разработку.
У многих на слуху, но его подписка во многом про то, чтобы у тебя был выбор из разных моделей.
А этот выбор, как бы, мало что даёт, если одна модель и так стабильно лучше.
Это Клод.
Если на работе тебя обязаны пользоваться или он уже встроен в вашу инфраструктуру, не страшно.
Особо там флоу не отличается.
Всё, по сути, то же самое.
Просто это не особо выгодно.
Следующий - это антигравити от Google.
По соотношению цена-возможности - это штука отличная.
Помимо того, что ты можешь пользоваться этими агентами, и Gemini, и Клодом.
Пользоваться различными внешними сервисами, генерировать видео, генерировать изображения.
Проводить глубокий ресерч.
Штука классная.
Если ты покупаешь аккаунт также, там, на полгода, то это тебе может выйти порядка тысячи рублей.
При таких возможностях, ну, как бы, цена беспрецедентная.
При этом, есть нюанс: Google постоянно банит, отслеживает кучу параметров и работает, на самом деле, непредсказуемо.
Как основной инструмент, с ним придётся попариться.
Поэтому, стоит ли экономия вот этих ограничений, нервов, я думаю, что нет.
И Клод-код, то, на чём работаем мы, он лучший и под агентские задачи, и под кодинг.
Проблемы у него тоже есть, но, как мы уже знаем, в гайде описано, как их обходить.
И ещё один момент, который стоит понять заранее, в какой форме мы вообще используем Клод, как мы с ним взаимодействуем.
Смотри, Клод, в первую очередь, нам потребуется локально на компе.
Это точно через браузер пользоваться нормально не получится.
Здесь у нас есть два варианта.
Тот, которым будем пользоваться мы в рамках курса, и тот, которым ты опционально можешь пользоваться.
В целом, по логике, ничего особо не меняется, но я всё-таки рекомендую первый.
Первый – это пользоваться через Visual Studio Code.
Ссылка, если что, на VS Code будет в описании под этим уроком.
Это совершенно бесплатное приложение для разработчиков.
Давай его откроем, посмотрим, как там это выглядит.
Вот интерфейс Visual Studio Code.
Слева у нас будут все файлы.
То есть, с агентами, с Клодом мы работаем именно в агентской среде.
Среда – это такая папочка, в которой хранятся все файлы, все указания для агента, все инструкции,
всё, о чём он должен знать, и всё то, что он делает.
То есть, например, проводит тебе приоритизацию фич или исследование конкурентов,
он сохраняет этот файлик здесь.
MD – это расширение текстовых файлов.
По сути, то же самое, что TXT, но просто как бы в таком формате,
в котором там есть заголовки первого, второго, третьего уровня и так далее.
В центре у нас открываются сами файлы, которые мы выбираем, тоже как бы ничего сложного нет.
Правой кнопкой мыши, если нажать на Tab, нажать Open Preview,
в более удобном формате с этим файлом можно ознакомиться, его прочитать.
Но редактировать здесь нельзя.
Здесь же редактировать можно.
Ну и справа сам Клод, с которым мы будем общаться.
Когда ты только открываешь VS Code, он предлагает тебе выбрать твой проект.
Мы здесь нажимаем Open, чтобы выбрать конкретную папку, в которой мы будем работать.
Это и будет нашей средой.
Выбираем ее и начинаем с ней работать.
Нажимаем открыть.
Здесь файлов у тебя изначально не будет.
Тебе дальше по ходу уроков будет дан файлик, будет описано, как там его запустить, развернуть и так далее.
Это все будет позже.
Здесь также тебе к VS Code стоит подключить этот сам Клод.
Ну, как бы не стоит, а необходимо.
Нажимаем расширение.
Здесь так это выглядит иконка.
Пишем Клод и находим расширение, которое называется Клод код, for VS Code, именно от издателя Anthropic.
Если мы сейчас напишем просто Клод, то увидим, что расширений тут очень много.
Нам нужно именно то, которое создано Anthropic.
Все.
После того, как ты его создал, любой файлик, который ты открываешь, здесь у тебя появляется иконочка Клода.
Можешь с ним чать.
Здесь он тебя попросит пройти авторизацию, нужно будет в браузере войти в свой аккаунт.
И на этом все.
Итак, в итоге, после этого урока и чтобы двигаться дальше по курсу нормально, тебе точно нужно собрать свой VPN.
Это вообще даже не обсуждается, тут вариантов нет.
Далее, решить вопрос с оплатой.
Также в гайде описано, как решить, ты будешь покупать аккаунт или заводить свой.
Здесь уже тоже есть ряд нюансов об этом подробнее в гайде.
Установить VS Code - это совершенно бесплатно.
И в него через расширение установить Клод код, как я ранее показал.
Все.
После этого ты будешь полностью готов к старту проходить всю программу.
Еще раз отмечу, что основной источник истины - это именно гайд.
Он будет в описании под этим уроком.
Мы его постоянно обновляем, чтобы он оставался актуальным.
На этом все.
Удачи с настройкой и увидимся уже в следующих уроках.